And the psychoanalyst,
I think,
err too much on the side of the subject.
They tend to think that too much of you
is inside of you and too little of us
outside of you.
And part of the reason I believe that is
because of my clinical experience.
I love the psychoanalyst Matt.
They're brilliant,
they're brilliant or deep.
They grapple with real problems like
with the problems when people have real
problems that I mean profound problems.
They're really profound moral problems
or problems of good and evil really.
You know,
there are things going on in their
family that are so terrible that well
that there are,
there are sometimes fatal,
you know,
lie upon,
lie upon lie for decades and decades and
decades.
It's awful.
And that's not exactly inside them.
It's out there in the world.
And lots of the people that I see,
very famous critic of psychology,
I can't remember his name,
but I probably will criticize the
practice of psychology quite effectively
in the believe in the early sixties.
The Myth of mental illness by Thomas
Sad,
zed,
a s zed.
It's classic.
You should read it if you're interested
in psychology.
Read it like it's.
It's a classic and he basically said,
most people have problems in living.
They don't have psychological problems,
and so I've experienced,
despite my love for the psychoanalysts,
very frequently what I'm doing as a
therapist is helping people have a life
that would work.
You know,
and you can parameterize that.
It's like,
what do you need?
How about some friends that people kind
of like that?
How about an intimate relationship with
someone that you can trust that maybe
has a future?
That'd be good.
How about a career that puts you in a
dominance hierarchy somewhere so at
least you've got some possibility of
rising,
some possibility of stabilizing yourself
and a schedule and a routine because no
one can live without a routine.
You just forget that if you guys don't
have a routine,
I would recommend you get one going
because you cannot be mentally healthy
without a routine.
You need to pick a time to get up
whatever time you want,
but pick one and stick to it because
otherwise you disregulate your circadian
rhythms and they regulate your mood and
eat something.
In the morning.
I had lots of clients who've that
anxiety disorders,
hired one client who was literally
starving,
very smart girl.
She was very little that she liked.
She kind of tried to subsist on like
half a cup of rice a day.
She came to me and said,
I have no energy.
I come home.
All I want to do is watch the same movie
over and over.
What?
Like,
is that weird?
And I thought,
well,
it depends on how hard you work.
You know,
it's a little weird,
but whatever.
It's familiar,
you're looking for comfort.
So I did an analysis of her diet.
It's like three quarters of a cup of
rice.
It's like you're starving,
eat something,
you know,
you'll feel better.
So she modified her diet and you're all
around.
Anxiety went away and she had some
energy.
It's like,
yeah,
you got to eat.
So schedule.
That's a good thing,
man.
Your brain will.
Thank you for it.
It will stabilize your nervous system
where there's a bit of a plan.
That's a good thing.
You need a career.
You need something productive to do with
your time.
You need to regulate your use of drugs
and alcohol.
Most particularly alcohol because that
does even a lot of people.
You need a family,
like the family,
you have your parents and all that.
It'd be nice if you all got along.
You could work on that.
That's a good thing to work on and then
you know,
you probably need children at some
point.
That's life.
That's what life is and if you're
missing,
you know,
you may have a good reason to not be
operating on one of those dimensions.
It's not mandatory,
but I can tell you that if you're not
operating reasonably well on four,
I think I mentioned six,
if you're not operating reasonably well
on at least three of them,
there's no way you're going to be
psychologically thriving and that's more
pragmatic in some sense than
psychological,
right?
Human beings have a nature.
There's things we need and if we have
them well that's good and if we don't
have them well then we feel the lack.
So behaviorists,
behavioral psychologists concentrate a
lot more on that sort of thing.
You know,
it's practical.
It's like strategizing.
Make a career plan,
figure out how to negotiate because
that's bloody important.
Figuring out how to say what you need,
figure out how to tell the truth to
people,
figure out how to listen to your partner
in particular because if you listen to
them,
they will actually tell you what they
want and sometimes you can give it to
them and maybe they'll return the favor.
And if you practice that for like 15
years,
well then maybe you're constantly giving
each other what you want.
Well Hooray.
That would be good.
And then there's two of you under both
circumstances and it's better to have
two brains than one because people think
differently because of their temperament
mostly.
And so the negotiation is where the
wisdom arises and it's part of the
transformation,
the psychological transformation that's
attendant on an intimate relationship,
and one of the fundamental purposes of a
longterm intimate relationship.